it's hard to run for president every day
is a test on how far you'll Bend for
approval
it's a limbo bar for your character no
matter how low others go you got to go
lower here's how the 2020 race is
shaping up for the Dems
so you're very bad he's doing it in a
restaurant anyway that is low but first
here's Kamala Harris getting low about
getting high have you ever smoked I have
okay I inhaled I didn't listen I think
that it gives a lot of people joy and we
what does carmella Harris listen to him
when he was high my goodness oh yeah
definitely snoop to pie for sure now you
could say she lied she was in school
before snoop or 2pac made records but
when you're high it's possible she
thought she was listening to them when
it was really this
[Applause]
[Music]
but Kamala was just playing character
limbo trying to convince the left that
she was rolling doobies not drug dealers
that's the pander a prosecutor
pretending that she never prosecuted
when asked if he would seek a female vp
cory booker pandered away if you got the
nomination would you commit to choosing
a woman as your vice presidential
running mate I think it would be
malpractice I'm not going to make any
specific commitments but we clearly
should I believe there should be a woman
president right now and it worked very
hard to get one but we have such a great
field of leaders I think that you will
rarely see a Democratic ticket anymore
without gender diversity race diversity
I think it's something that we should
have so I'm not gonna box myself in but
should I become it you know I'll be
looking to women first looking to women
first a perfect gentleman doing the
limbo he knows a man should open the
door for a woman figuratively not
literally that would be sexist and when
Howard Schultz was asked about taxes he
said this but the headline is here I
should be paying more taxes and people
who make this kind of revenue and of
means should make should pay more taxes
of course rich people who say they want
to pay more taxes are just rolling under
the limbo Pole here's a tip Howie write
a check to the US government sign it and
leave it blank the IRS will do the rest
but the queen of pandering Liz Warren
showing up at a Native American
conference she can't stop because she's
a politician and politicians will do
anything for approval which is why this
chap is so refreshing how easy it is to
be presidential but you'd all be out of
here right now but you'd be so bored we
got more money we got more brains we got
better houses apartments we got nicer
boats I went to better schools I went to
better everything I'm president and
they're not who love your dogs don't you
I wouldn't mind having one honestly but
I don't have any time
how would I look lucky to dog on the
White House Lord here's a little phony
phony to me that's the opposite of
pandering while everyone else is buying
a focus group to breed of caca poodle he
says nope not for me I guess he likes
his animals
well done huh Dana did you find that
offensive what we're talking about this
yesterday you find it offensive that he
said it in like dogs or do you respect
him for being honest so I respect him
for being on it's like when I would say
like I'm not I like a cat yes but I
don't want to have a cat I hear you
no offense Angie at home with 4 rescue
cats in Denver they're not really ready
was easier yes before social media and
before the 24/7 news cycle because you
could go to an event in Iowa and say I
love ethanol right you could go
someplace else and say oh absolutely
I'm absolutely for more solar panels you
betcha I am and no one would ever know
and that's how you could cobble together
a coalition now it's to you it's
impossible Jesse when you listen to
Trump to see pander enough I think he
can pander more imitation of Democrats
correct that was such a brilliant
monologue Greg you know I used to write
monologues when I was in college I
always thought about writing a book of
all my monologues do you have that idea
yes brother so that's what they do
okay and this is why they do it it's
because this there's participating in
the pandering Olympics because what they
do is their base is all filled up with
specific interest groups you know the
gays the blacks the Hispanics the women
and when they try to be everything to
everybody they spread themselves so thin
there's no core there so Kamala
you're not hip-hop Trump's more hip-hop
than you are Schultz be a billionaire
your own it you know if you want to pay
more taxes you check the box Cory
Booker's should pick the most qualified
VP candidate when you're not doing that
you look unqualified an Elizabeth Warren
stop apologizing to Native Americans
there's other population groups out
there soccer moms for instance they
should be your focus Wisconsin hey you
know one I'm gonna say something nice
about Kamala Harris during that during
that interview she didn't talk about the
medicinal qualities of marijuana
she mentioned joy which is the first
time a politician I have seen a
in this stance admit that recreational
use of marijuana is actually okay which
i think is like that's not pandering
that's actually a step forward wow she
got your vote yes because nobody
everybody hides behind medicinal there
was no oh I'm forward to criminalization
for medicinal effect you're gonna need
to smoke weed when she takes your health
care but I like the fact that she said
no yeah it brings people joy that's the
real argument in my blog that seemed
authentic to me but I don't I mean I'm
trying to figure out because to me you
saying this is Democrats and I thinking
to myself I just went through 2016 right
where I believe on Cinco DeMayo Trump
said best taco Rowling
and of course he goes to West Virginia
what's he do he puts on a coal miners
hat yes what about talking to the
Christian evangelicals he says oh you
know I don't go to church but what I do
I don't ask for forgiveness name says oh
wait a second when I take my little bit
of wine and my little bit of cracker
he's doing it in a way that everybody
knows he's pandering speak with instead
of changing their message and their
character for each group I think just
sticks with the white nationalists I
have a theory that anybody who doesn't
fit into an acceptable acceptable frame
Canton can no longer run for president
and then Trump changed that he says it's
okay to be a jerk and go out and say
what you want he's also just being
himself he's not afraid to be himself
that love him or hate him that this is
what he is this is what he's like this
is probably how he stalks his family
this is how he stalks his friends he's
not putting it on for the camera and I
think the Democrats are just trying
really hard to be liked I liked that
qumola interview because that was the
first time that I saw her just being
herself I believe
you fart I believe that she smokes even
though she might be lying about what you
don't because I think that she thought
she heard something else yeah two people
asking you something I think it's some
Patrice she probably does hi and was
listening to that but it was a humanity
that I saw in her and I don't understand
why they keep putting out this rehearsed
nonsense all of those politicians
Hillary Clinton that try so hard to be
liked they don't win the people that
actually win elections are the people
that are real and authentic Joe Biden's
an example on the left I think Barack
Obama to an extent that's just who he
was Trump is an example just be yourself
and if you know if you're grumpy or
whatever that is that's your thing use
it people might actually like it whoever
thought that Trump doing what he does
would get him elected by the way by the
way I'm just so confused you know some
days that the five I get Kim what do you
know what we feel when you talk yeah I
just said that Trump is a jerk but he's
an authentic he's a non PC New York guy
he ran a business but why would you call
him I think I'm saying in this day and
age an honest person is seen as a jerk
and that's too bad I think that's not
true I don't think I think are we all
you're I'm a jerk oh I know I'm a jerk I
embrace my inner jerk him